تعد طائره اف 16 من اكثر المقاتلات طلبا
حول العالم وتستخدمها قرابه خمس وعشرين
دوله
صنعت شركه جنرال ديناميكس الامريكيه
النموذج الاول منها في سبعينيات القرن
الماضي لصالح سلاح الجو الامريكي دخلت
الخدمه عام
تتميز بخفه وزنها وقدراتها القتاليه
العاليه هجوميا ودفاعيا ويمكن استخدامها
في هجمات مضاده ودعم جوي قريب المدى اضافه
لمهام المراقبه الجويه
يمكنها تحديد الاهداف في جميع الظروف
الجويه واكتشاف الطائرات التي تحلق على
ارتفاعات منخفضه يصل مداها الاقصى لنحو
وبامكانها حمل سته صواريخ
تتيح المقاتله مجال رؤيه خاليا من العوائق
في اتجاهي الامامي والاعلى وبعد ادخال
تحديثات عليها تحسن مجال رؤيه الطيار في
الجوانب والخلف
تحتوي على انظمه تحديد مواقع عالميه محسنه
ونظام ملاحه عالي الدقه تقدم اجهزه
الحاسوب على متنها معلومات توجيه للطيارين
ولديها اجراءات مضاده يمكن استخدامها لصد
التهديدات الالكترونيه
تتميز اف 16 ايضا بقوه راداراتها وقدرتها
الفائقه على تحديد الاهداف على الارض هذه
المميزات تجعل من نفس 16 مناسبه لتوفير
غطاء جوي للقوات الاوكرانيه اثناء المعارك
البريه مع الجيش الروسي بحسب خبراء ويمكن
لها ان تتيح تقدم القوات برا وتساعد في صد
الطائرات الروسيه تقول كييف ان هذه
الطائرات يمكن ان تتيح لها الدفاع عن خطوط
الشحن البحريه وتامين مغادره الحبوب
الاوكرانيه للبلاد ويقول خبراء ان حصول
اوكرانيا على هذه الطائرات يمكن ان يغير
جوهريا من شكل الصراع باتت اوكرانيا اقرب
من اي وقت مضى للحصول على اف 16 مع عدم
اعتراض امريكي واستعداد بعض الدول
لتزويدها بطائرات من النماذج الاقدم ضمن
ما باتي يعرف بتحالف الطائرات الذي تشكل
في ايار مايو الماضي ويضم احدى عشره دوله
وتقوده هولندا والدنمارك ويشمل ايضا
المانيا وفرنسا وبريطانيا وبولندا وبلجيكا
والبرتغال
[موسيقى]